don't bring anyone love into this and
how long have you doing stand-up at this
point maybe two you know the first time
I ever not the first with a feet well
actually the first time I've ever got a
sage I was 15
really 15 and yeah the fourth time I
ever got on stage luckily or unluckily I
had to open for Sam Kinison oh my god it
was the time was never okay I'm in San
Antonio 19 years old I think maybe 20
1920 and I did a comedy competition
contest not competition yeah at a bar
and there were five of us and I had done
comedy maybe two or three times before
when I was in high school and it's been
a while since you've done it yeah but I
mean even at that age you know I was
basically the first time I ever got on
stage I asked the guy who put on the
show what should I talk about he said
talk about what you know and what I
really knew is that my parents fart all
the time so I did five minutes about
them far like our son yeah I closed and
it was so funny because my mom didn't
know what I was gonna talk about and so
when I walked onstage I could hear her
she was in the front row with one of
those cameras you know yeah and then I
started to talk about her farting and it
gets slower like z.z but but I closed
with the story about how we were driving
down the Mass Pike yeah when I was a kid
and my mom was farting like crazy in the
car we were in the back of the station
wagon with our head out that you know
the back window yeah and my dad pulls
over on the freeway and he goes to my
mom
Ellen you gotta get out yeah and she was
like what and he goes you're killer
you're really killing the car you got to
get out she goes what do you me to do he
goes I don't know walk it off something
so she walked up and down the side of
the highway for like five minutes party
just letting it air out you know she's
like a walk farter yeah
so those are the jokes I'd done yeah
that's what it that's solid I go to San
Antonio I do my stand that's you for
like by the way a third or fourth time
right yeah so I go I win because the bar
was packed full of my friends yeah Sam
kinnison's coming to town his opener
Carla bow you know Carl yes
so Carl's dad at the time and I think I
hope I'm not mminton this up but I think
that's his dad had died of AIDS I think
is what he had died his dad but he died
for something on the way to San Antonio
they need a new opener for Sam Kinison
so they go hey who won that comedy
competition oh no and so I get a phone
call in my dorm room oh hey do you want
to open for Sam Kinison and I believe
the name of the club in San Antonio was
sneakers and weight to be clear at this
time is he a huge megastar at this time
huge megastar okay so it's not like oh
that's kind of yeah he's working
no he's Sam Kinison okay he's Sam
Kinison any Sam Kinison to the point
where he's at the point of his career
where he's told everybody he's sober all
right he's not so he's not yeah but it
was the 90s you didn't have the
Internet's all you to do is say I'm
sober and people like he's yeah that's
the end of that so here's a talk about
fashion by the way here's how confused I
am when I show up I am wearing black
cowboy boots with the silver ding at the
tip I have basically white acid-washed
pretty baggy jeans I'm wearing I'm
confused because I don't know what to
wear I'm wearing a blue button-down
shirt not tuck no I'm sorry tucked in
with one of those thin black belts I
have my hair it that hair in a ponytail
mm-hm and I'm wearing that black leather
jacket I showed you in the first over
over my blue button-down shirt tucked
into my acid-wash jeans you look like
such a dick the biggest dick in the
world and I'm standing in front of a
crowd you know as comedians when people
are there to see there
guy and that it's Tennessee yeah and
it's not at a comedy club it's at a rock
club - tell me I have so much anxiety
like do you do okay so do you know how
much material you have fourth time on
stage oh man should you be standing in
front of a rock crowd like that sold out
sold out and it's just one of the roof
because he's he's the first rock n'roll
comedian oh yeah do you know what I mean
so it's that people are not sitting down
either it's the first time especially I
had ever seen anything like that it's a
fourth time on stage I don't know what
I'm doing
no emcee no no I'm sick just voice of
God no to bring out you and to go up
cold is like death and like they it
would have been Carlisle probably doing
just slinging jokes for like 25 minutes
just well that was my time 25 minute no
do you how much material I had that
farting bit yeah I had like three and a
half if I stretched it a little bit you
know what I mean sweating right so tough
I walk on stage and I and this is how
poorly it went by it by and I have I'm
supposed to do 25 minutes this is how
poor they went by minute four maybe five
they had already stopped heckling me and
they were just talking to each other
they had stopped I was doing so poorly
they had just started talking to each
other that's good so for the next 20
minutes you stayed up there that long
stayed up the whole time
I even repeated because I only had five
minutes of material
I opened would fight that five closed
with the same five because I even said I
was like hey for those of you came in
late who might have missed the first
five minutes of the set because I knew I
had five minutes left and I didn't know
what the fuck were you trying how do
they time sets then I had a little clock
yeah okay to show night no no does
anyone show you mercy
like are you pulled off stage and not
only am I not showing mercy
bill his brother and manager yeah
clearly didn't watch my set
and after how's it going man everything
after Sam set and Sam was visibly fucked
up the first show yeah so they were like
oh man
house he was like listen man for this
second show which we're going to try to
get Sam straightened out so we may need
you to stretch a little bit no I was
like I almost felt like saying did you
not watch the first show I was hoping
instead of this we would do some of this
yeah you know we could shorten it
instead of lengthen it so he was like
look over to me at about 20 minutes and
if I start to do this you gotta stretch
it terrible they don't know they're
working with a guy who's done
interesting up four times at 18 minutes
yeah because I know at 20 I gotta look
over them I literally start to flop
sweat because I'm thinking if I have to
do a minute more than I did in the early
show I don't know I'm worse they're
drunker oh yeah it's late but they're
out its kinnison's crowds they've been
the show second show started late
they've been waiting outside for 45
minutes like caged animals and they
finally got let loose on me it was a
shit show I ended up doing 30 the second
show oh my god but I will tell you
something and it was maybe the worst to
worst sets I've ever had in my life for
a bunch of reasons but you know what it
did very early on it just showed me I
can whatever happens it's never gonna
get worse than that because the same
thing happened that second show they
just stopped paying attention to that I
was even there do you remember getting
paid I didn't get paid it was just like
a much do you want open for Sam Kinison
that's it $0 do you remember what you
were saying up there oh yeah yeah I do
it was not it was not great hey hey you
did crowd work did you try them I did
one joke about how I had just read about
how there was a guy who died and his
wife still wanted to have visit true the
news story his wife still wanted a
babies with the with a guy and after he
died told the doctor how do I still have
babies for this guy
and the joke was I mean that's terrible
can you imagine being that doctor just
like all right right so it was a fake it
was a joke about a doctor jerking off a
dead guy not a bad joke actually not
terrible and I'm messing up a little bit
of the setup but that was the closure
right so what you're talking about which
I agree with you not bad for the man I'm
terrible but not a closer
you must have had some some people have
some chuckles in that crowd right a few
I don't think so I think I had some I
think I I think it was that venue well
so I think you know looking back on
things they grow in scope sometimes and
I'm it's been however many years I was
more than 20 years I but had to be rock
club in San Antonio 500 people yeah
seems about right but I was rough and I
will say that is probably one of the
tougher crowds to do because you're that
guy was a rock star so you've got that
rowdy energy you've got people highest
fuck drunk as fuck
Candis and Kinnison was a screamer and
high energy so you that's your audience
that's terrifying
[Music]